[Music]
thank you
Jonas we need your help
we're detecting increased aquatic
activity 25 000 feet deep in the trench
it's an ancient ecosystem Untouched by
man whatever is down there is trying to
make its way to the surface
this is a bad idea just a little bit
[Music]
foreign
biggest Meg anyone's ever seen
everybody back into the station
three massive exit who knows what else
have escaped the breach
I just hope it goes better than last
time
what happened last time
I don't know
[Applause]
we've never seen this before they hunted
it back
we can relax this place is magproof when
Jonas was always afraid of this but I
was also thinking
[Music]
barracuda